good morning john good morning six
years ago we held the first quadrantual
quadragon it was a series of tests
of endurance and skill the idea was that
every four years for the rest of our
lives hank and i would test one another
against
each other and through a combination of
our own laziness
and also a global pandemic we are about
two years late
with the second quadrant quadragon but
here we are we are in the same place at
the same time and we are gonna
could drag the heck out of this deck
we're gonna quad drag it on
[Music]
john we're gonna play to the spigot
you may be wondering if i have a
strategy the answer is yes it is to put
as many
events that involve endurance as close
together as possible because i know i
have
more endurance than hank i've seen a lot
of reality television and one thing they
always say is like
i'm in it to win it i'm going to be here
to the end i'm not
like i'm not feeling good about this i
don't think i have it in me and i think
that like one that's okay but second is
my brother so i would like to win
but i don't hey we're going to get into
the next event
[Music]
brick
close but it was not as far as me i feel
like it's a real disservice to the
landscape to show your face from below
when you could be showing the landscape
[Music]
how are you it's giving rocks jon i
didn't pick this event
one one
[Music]
okay you win
we're watching an olympian at work
37 seconds i feel like never having
played this game
but we're tired so
oh was bad okay we made collage art
and i'm tweeting which one is better
john's very close
oh no okay we've let like an hour go by
very close
but you have won great for me yesterday
obviously i had a rough day too not
least because hank introduced a bunch of
events that i have absolutely no
expertise in
i need cup stacking to get the draw i'm
all in on cup stacking i've been
practicing
i've been doing some mental exercises
thinking through cup stacking and i feel
i feel ready look i don't think i'm
gonna be good at this but i think john
might be worse
three two one start
oh geez i don't know how to do this
boy that's good that's fast
that 14 13 something it's a draw
it's a draw it extends we will we won't
know for sure who the real
quick dragonian is for another four to
six years
but we all know who the real winner is
john everyone besides us
thank you and i'll see you now and let
us know what we should do for our video
on 2-0 it's gonna be our last video
together
last collab video three in a row gotta
make up gotta make up for last time
okay we need you to stay ready
ready set go
what a cheater you okay john yeah
i know you run a lot i don't usually run
that fast no i nev
that's the fastest i've run probably
since the last quadragon
wow